a child is now blind because of abuse he
suffered this is a story our i-team
brought to you in february
this afternoon we hear from the boy
himself our i-team's vanessa murphy has
the story you'll only see here
life for marcus gray is different since
this photo was taken
the nine-year-old boy is now blind after
a beating with a belt
last november what did i do wrong to me
there's nothing that you could have
ever done to deserve for this to happen
to you
nothing his paternal grandmother deborah
evans cares for him
metro police say akoya hudgins hit
marcus with a belt
to discipline him he was the live-in
boyfriend of marcus's mother jareshon
jackson
even after they knew marcus was hurt
jackson didn't take him to the hospital
until six days later hudgins and jackson
were eventually arrested
hudgins apologized during this interview
with the i-team from jail
in february as i was going to swing the
belt
the kid like turned around like this
and i accidentally hit him in the face
a doctor explained in front of the grand
jury for injuries like marcus's
his eyesight may have been saved if he
had received
medical treatment sooner why didn't you
get him help
i told her to get it checked out you
know to see
how's ours are doing but i'm not the
parent so i can't go and take him
and get him checked out you're not the
parent
but you were hitting him with a belt
right yes
marcus is adapting to his new normal
last time
i could see shadows and
and yeah shadows but now i can't
evan says he's learning braille now and
doing well in school
he spends time listening to music his
favorites katy perry
lady gaga and taylor swift
and he's a fan of the arts i like
ballet gymnastics
cheerleading he's very unique
he's a very unique little kid what does
that mean um
unique meaning that you do some
awesome stuff sometimes what do you want
to be when you grow up
i guess i want to be a
cheerleading group another wish surgery
so he can see again
evan says doctors say they've done what
they can but
she and marcus are holding on to hope he
was hurt nearly
one year ago for evans it's tough to
think about
hudgens pleaded guilty to child abuse
and was sentenced 4-10 years in prison
jackson is awaiting trial evans says she
and marcus are taking it one day
at a time he should have never had to
ever experience none of this
vanessa murphy 8 news now
deborah evans says marcus's teacher told
her he's doing so well in school that he
could
be in a gifted program